<人魚>
<それは→
<上半身が人間→
<下半身が魚でできている→
<怪物のことである>
はじめしゃちょーです
えー…と　ぼくですね　あの
結構カナヅチというか　もうほんと…
そもそも運動が…なんかちょっと…
音痴なんですよね
25mもようやくなんとか泳げるぐらいで
ほんとに下手くそで〜→
それでもやっぱりぼくは↗︎
そんな私のために
こんなものがありました
はい！
アクアマーメイドなんとかなんとか！
ご覧くださいまし
こんな綺麗な人魚姫がたくさんいますね
はいというわけで今の見てわかると
思うんですけども　これ→
↘︎らしいです
ちょっと英語で色々→
書いてあるんですけど
読んでいきましょうか
え〜　Swiming◎△＄♪×￥●＆％＃...
>>早送り>>
ォーケイ。
はい　あの…
いやわかります。
簡単に言うとですね↗︎
「あなたはほんとに人魚になれる体験が
これでできます」
「マーメイドのヒレを使って泳ぐ方法を
しっかり学んで頑張れ」
って書いてあります。
これ多分スゴイっスよ
ほんとになんか動画見たんですけども
ほんとになんか人魚っていうか→
お魚さんみたいに人間が泳いでて→
ワンチャンこれ　泳げないぼくでも
泳げるんじゃないか説があるんで〜→
今回はこれを使って↗︎
1回開けてみましょう。
開封の儀をしたいんですけど→
ここでちょっと人魚のヒレを傷つける
わけにはいかないので→
普通に開けまーす
お！
え　シンプル
え　すごい！
オレ　これでナイトプール行きたい
ハッハッハー！
おぉ　えぇ　すごい！
めっちゃ中もしっかりしてるー
これマジでちゃんと泳げるやつだな多分
え　スゴーイ！
これを履けば泳げるってことか…
というわけで早速
海に行ってこようと思います！
♪〜
[波の音]
これ大丈夫！？
(けんすけ)どう見ても　もう…
アリエルだけども！
こんにちは
入ります
じゃあまず　泳いでみましょう早速
(けんすけ)はい　お願いしまーす！
(けんすけ)ッッハハハハハｗｗｗｗ
(けんすけ)泳げますよ　どう見ても
♪〜
(けんすけ)お！ｗｗ
(はじめ)どう？　待って　むず！
♪〜
(けんすけ)ｗｗｗｗｗ
これさぁ難しいっスわ
現段階のぼくのマーメイド力だと
無理っスねー多分
(けんすけ)なるほどなるほど
泳げてたぁ？
(けんすけ)まぁなんとなく
というわけで早速
なるべく奥まで行ってみようと思います
行くぞォッ！！
♪〜
まるでマーメイドラグーンの気分ですね
がんばるよぉ〜〜
♪〜
(はじめ)わ゛
♪〜(悲しい音楽)
ぶぅぅ
[ED ♪〜(悲しい音楽)]